hey everyone welcome to the walleye
podcast i'm james marshall and thanks
for tuning in to another episode firstly
quick shout out to todd's racing the
champion harness trainer regan todd is
flying at the moment so make sure you go
give them a follow on their facebook or
their twitter that would be very much
appreciated and while we are there if
you enjoy this podcast make sure that
you are following the waterlet instagram
account or the facebook page or
subscribe to the youtube channel or if
you are the ultimate lads sign up to the
lads club for discounts and some
exclusive pranks coming soon
to sign up head over to wallet.com
scroll down the bottom it'll say become
a lad type in your email and then that's
it that's all you have to do and you're
in the lads club forever welcome go do
that anyway i've got a great lad for you
today so let's roll the intro
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what a land right team now i'm really
looking forward to this one as i have a
recent olympic medalist on the show
who's not only coached the new zealand
sevens team to all sorts of success over
the last few years he's actually done it
all from carving up on the seventh
circuit himself for scotland to
successfully coaching his side such as
taranaki the hurricanes and london irish
and of course you all know it he is an
absolute lad he's one of the greatest
scottish kiwis of all time it is the
great clark laidlaw welcome clarkie
hell hell the build up unless you're
about the carbon up part on the seven
series but i'll take it
you're on there for a long time though
hey longer than i thought yeah off and
on so i played the 2000 originally and
then i went to 15s for a couple years
and
didn't last too long there got kicked
out my contract and then went back to
seventh 2000 then
before i think played yeah played 18
tournaments um at the back end there so
yeah off and on
you must have been you must have been a
gun
18 tournament yeah 18 16 more than me
yeah well that's right i think the heat
got you in dubai didn't it
i didn't get on enough
i remember you getting sunburned on your
forehead because you want to give it a
cut
oh that rule used to break me
oh titch wouldn't let me wear my cat i
used to get the lasagna the burnt and
the little that's where my hat used to
protect me and oh training training in
the heat what was it 30 odd degrees
sun beaming down not allowed to wear my
hat
sweat dripping in the eyes
just one of those unnecessary rules
hopefully you've changed that i see
you're wearing a hat now yeah that's
because of my um that's because i'm
going bald and gray so that's why i've
got hot one
yeah that's the gray part so always wear
the hat
anyway mate really appreciate you coming
on the podcast um i know you're a busy
man in isolation
biking marathons every single day
talk to me about that what's what's the
reason behind that one
um
i over the last year had a tough year uh
my mum passed away
just over a year ago um and my dad was
diagnosed with with alzheimer's so
my little brother chris back home he he
decided to take on a challenge 12 and 12
which is he's going to run 12 marathons
in 12 months and obviously you know i
can't be there to either support him i'm
not
i'm not sure i'd be there to run one
even if i was in scotland um
so yeah i just thought i would do my uh
do my best try and have a little bit of
awareness for his give a little page so
it's 12 and 12. chris laidlaw
um give a little so he's giving back to
the three charities that really helped
us out so the injured players
which is a scottish charity um for
injured rugby players um
alzheimer's scotland
who supported my old man and then the
married curie which is the nurses that
came in and helped my mum and stayed
home she'd uh i guess a short battle
with cancer so
so yeah it's something that's pretty
close to always the family's hearts so
if i can you know raise a little bit of
awareness by
sitting on my little horse here each day
then you know hopefully hopefully i can
help him and his
uh he's done seven so he's he's got a
few to go he did his first one back home
in the weekend a couple of weekends ago
so
so yeah see if we can do my part for
that oh mate you're a good man so how
many how many bikes are you in already
one
how was it
it was all good the the bigger the
bigger laugh was some of the boys
decided to they reckon they were going
to join in so we've all got bikes in the
rooms
i think i'm the only one with a walk
bike because i i got in touch um because
i knew i was going to do it
so i think the biggest laugh was tim
nicholson tried to ride it he couldn't
get the seat high enough um aquila
roccola saw finished by sitting on the
ground pedaling
um
so i think some of the boys might be one
one and done i see joe webber um posted
one and said you'll see me in three days
he's off back to bed so
so yeah it was pretty cool yesterday a
few boys jumped jumped on board and
done a few the management are getting
involved um
but i think the range of bikes might um
stop a few doing the 12. yeah so what's
your plan of attack today when are you
going to attack it is there a perfect
time for you no i went at 2 o'clock
yesterday it seemed like quite good
times had a lazy morning uh a couple of
calls this morning so i'll probably go
go after lunchtime again seems like i
think the afternoons will drag a little
bit here in miq so the mornings seem to
go reasonably quickly usually because
it's an early start for us at 9 30 but
so yeah i'll jump on after lunchtime
again and knock one out oh man you're a
good man and i strongly recommend anyone
who can who's listening who can donate
to go check out that and donate if you
can i'll chuck the link at the bottom of
the
podcast when i release it so make sure
you go give that a click and donate what
you can for a good cause and a couple of
good people
your brother he is a legend running 12
marathons in 12 12 months that's a tough
gig
yeah but anyway let's talk about the
olympics because
obviously mate it was awesome to see you
guys on the biggest stage at the
olympics and amazing achievement to get
your silver medal but you would be
feeling a little bit disappointed not to
go one peter i'd imagine
yeah i think so man it's um
it's quite a mixed emotions isn't it
it's usually when you play give a rugby
or a tournament you sort of win or you
lose yeah
um and you feel like you can you can
sort of accept that and winning our
silver and olympics
you know i think a reflection is a
pretty amazing achievement for for the
players and the team um but i guess
we're competitiveness and we certainly
went there with with our ambition to win
on gold you know i think it's mixed
emotions
um i'm sure you know as we get through
the next two weeks um
i guess the the winning and losing the
tournament will probably fade
you know and i think we all know that
and rugby yeah
at the time it's the most important
thing in the world isn't it to
to try and win and man we put we put so
much effort over the last three or four
years to try and put a team there could
win and yeah
um but i think the overriding thing from
email is going to be
sort of real satisfaction and pride
around the group of men we've developed
on and off the field we're bloody lucky
that
we've got a great group you know we we
spent sort of three hours after the
tournament sitting in the changing room
just yarning to each other and talking
about you know the last few years and
sharing some memories and
and thanking each other and i think
that'll be the thing
is you know me in a changing room it's
probably the thing
nobody can ever get you know you can't
buy that feeling you get is a tight
group um
and again simmons is even tighter isn't
it it's a small group and it was only 13
players and a few management so so that
two or three hours after the tournament
i think is probably once the
you know the
initial disappointment not being able to
get a gold
that's the thing that'll stay with me
but
um
yeah mixed emotions is probably easy way
describing it so
super proud of how we prepared and
played but
as you know against fiji a couple of
those little opportunities that got away
from us um you know i thought we didn't
react to one of the kickoffs quick
enough
um you know we lost the ball a little
fly hack through that they got a little
bit lucky with and then
in 1912 i felt like we'd wrestled the
game back you know the momentum was was
probably with us we were hanging in
there and
i think we'd scored in 1912 it felt like
we could come over the top um
but again we missed an opportunity of
that left hand side and then you know
they were good enough to go down and
and eventually score off a big ball and
play which you know took the game away
from us so
it was an unbelievable experience so i'm
sure you want to talk about that but man
olympics was
unreal
yeah well the thing about sevens that
you mentioned there is one on such small
margins eh like it's the smallest thing
can turn a game and sometimes a kit can
win it but it's the smallest uh margins
that win or lose your game so how how
hard is that to prepare for and plan for
i think that's the beauty of savings
like why
quite helps develop players you know
develops fitness staff and coaches and
players because you have to
you've got no room for error you know
you miss one clean you drop a ball you
miss one tackle
this one kick off that can be the game
you know and 15's
very rarely is it is it one in lost or
just a tiny little moment um
so it really puts you know your skills
your decision making and the real
pressure um
and preparing for it you know you know
that's the ultimate game of consequence
when you go in there you know especially
against the best teams
that it doesn't take much you know if
you look at the australian game we were
you know 12-0 down out of nowhere and as
you say
andre you stop kicking a conversion from
the sideline to to get us back in the
game and
you know then we scored another try we
went 1412 so it's
you know
as much as we lost the game on five
margins we we certainly won a couple
on similar fight margins
so it's i think that's what makes it so
exciting especially in the men's game
there's
there's nothing between the teams you
know you look at south africa missing a
quarter final who
argentina were down to six men with i
think it was 12 minutes to go
so it was a crazy you know
crazy tournament that that we all know
any of the teams can beat anybody so i
think that's why
it looks like it's been going pretty
well on social media and tv and stuff
and how tough was the um rescheduling of
the tournament for you guys obviously it
got pushed back
um you'd planned for a long time to have
the tournament at a certain date and
then all got pushed back how hard was
that to adapt to
oh yeah it was difficult it was um
there was a number of fronts you know
the program got shut down for for three
months
all the staff
apart from i think was four of us across
the two teams
we went down to three days a week the
rest of staff didn't have a job for
three months
so that was that was bloody difficult um
you know certain players
were here and i went to 15s and you know
we got most of them back but not all of
them back you know so it changed the
makeup of our squads
i think there's a couple of things we
put into a game that we thought was
ready to peak last year and then maybe
teams got a read on you know defensive
system or
some areas in the game that you know all
of a sudden had another year and a bit
for people to have a look at rather than
just
four or five months um
but all in all me you know i was
again it was
an amazing um amazingly proud of how the
group responded to all that
by the time we all got back together
just after christmas we weren't really
back together until until january you
know all staff all players um and it
kind of felt
it gave us an actual boost because
everybody missed missed being together
so much so the players and staff i think
had a real boost i think that some of
the players that went to 15's realized
why they love simmons so much yeah and
then we realized how well you know we do
stuff and how well looked after they are
from a training perspective and um so
that that was actually a real positive
that some guys had went away and
you look at something like
nicole who went to southland probably
realized that you know he was he was
easily good enough to be a
an npc player came back with a lot of
confidence um in his own game and
he was somebody that we thought you know
got a real benefit from going to 15s
then coming back and realizing you know
that he actually done some stuff really
well and
um his game was probably further ahead
than he realized so
so i think in some ways it was really
you know it was really tough and
you wouldn't want to go through that too
often but
in other ways it gave guys like a scott
curry you know he's another one had
never played npc
ended up becoming the
true hybrid player didn't he played six
eight and 12.
um
so so guys like that you know got to do
stuff that maybe
you know maybe in a normal olympic cycle
i mean i've got to do so
there's always positives isn't that you
know if you look at if you look for
opportunities there was some certainly
good positives there too yeah well you
mentioned that the boys were well looked
after in terms of um training and stuff
you've obviously changed the program up
there because
no one has ever talked
highly of the sevens training schedule
it's usually a real tough slog so what's
changed
it's still a tough slog
i think i guess we try and use a fair
bit of sports science to prepare the
players um
so you know we can't you can't just
train hard all day every day can you so
so there's a real specific nature to to
how we try and prepare based off you
know based off of what the game looks
like
um we've genuinely tried to create an
environment where players love to be
part of it and have a lot of fun and
and build really good connections on and
off the field
with something you know we thought was
important coming out the back of the
last olympics
centralizing the team
you know we're not we're not like every
national team where you come together
for short periods i guess we're more
we're almost more like a super rugby
team on uh npc side because we're
together the whole year so it's really
important to get that balance right mate
around
working hard working smart
having fun
and i think in the main you know we've
done a really good job at that but it is
hard you know i sometimes think or
wonder if that's why a few 15s players
um you know steer clear of sevens
because
people talk how hard it is and it is you
know it's a brutal game isn't it but
it's a great game for for any young
player or player that wants to develop
you know skill development under
pressure
build some resilience that that you all
need to to succeed at the top level 100
couldn't agree more with that oh so it's
massive
development tool for rugby and i feel
like it's
sort of under used at the moment i
reckon no and that's you know it's
another challenge we've got now is you
know what what the sevens in the country
look like uh we've also got the red bull
tournament that was a huge success yeah
but it's it's definitely a challenge you
know the condors
in the world schools is an amazing event
for your 17 18 year olds but we
certainly you know in my opinion
we still need some sort of provincial
involvement in simmons man after being
in olympic games i can't understand why
everybody involved in rugby doesn't want
to play sevens it's
it's a hell of an experience to to go
and rub shoulders with the best athletes
in the world and
the biggest stage um you know males and
females
you look at what girls have done and you
know the sort of profile they can bring
to inspire the next generation rugby
players is huge were you surprised not
to get more super rugby players make
themselves available for the tournament
the guys like riyasi and stuff who sort
of turned it down
i'm not sure if i'm surprised i'm
disappointed or i think after being the
olympics i'm a little bit confused why
players wouldn't want to go
you know you're at dinner with djokovic
you know you're walking around watching
the nba
french basketballers the spanish guys or
you know even the best athletes that
you're watching on tv now um some of the
new zealand's
best sports stars you know from road to
track cycling you know lisa canton and
so on it's i think we need to find a way
of of
opening up people's idea to what the
olympics says it's the biggest sporting
event in the world
it's not you know it's not a 15's game
that only
five six countries might
watch um 10 if you're lucky it's it's
every country every corner of the world
every sport you can think of
so hopefully over the next few while we
can try and get around and you know
whether it's part of our um player
development or educational younger
players around what it feels like
and hopefully some of our younger
players can can try and
share their stories around what olympics
felt like to try and inspire that next
generation you know i think it's easy in
the women's game because our girls are
on the pinnacle of the sport under the
seventh girls have been you know i guess
like the all blacks so for us we need to
yeah try and open up people's idea to
what what planet olympics could look
like
and you mentioned the olympic village
there that what so nothing really
changed with the covert lockdown it was
still mingling with some of the biggest
names in the game and being able to go
and watch other games etc no we weren't
able to go and watch um which was hugely
disappointing i think it would have been
an unbelievable olympics and in tokyo it
looked so well set up um
the village were to wear masks and
basically went to the the food hall got
you know wash your hands put your gloves
on yeah got your food sat as far away
from
other people as possible and then went
back to your uh your apartment but
it's just that it's the atmosphere it's
it's something you can't really you know
put your finger on it's been part of our
bigger new zealand team
um not just rugby where you know i think
in rugby we can become um
you know people talk about being in a
bubble
with covid but i think in 15s you're
genuinely in a bubble you go to a hotel
you don't see your opposition you play
them on a saturday then you go home
again whereas
being part of the olympic team welcoming
in you know our boys done an amazing job
getting part of
the nzoc team welcome
other sports in um
mingling with where the tv was and
getting coffees together um
watching people come back with medals is
it it's an amazing atmosphere and
something
you know the other things that you
probably remember more is
um you know watching those roars come
back with all their medals was
and watching our you know our men almost
being all of you know of another sport
and
um it's pretty cool um and it's as i say
not not just being in rugby and being
involved in a bigger wider team is it's
a great experience yeah and who was the
biggest celebrity to come get a photo
with you
i think my mask must have hit me um
nobody went out their way to get a
selfie so
we were seriously tempted when we've
seen djokovic to go and ask him for a
for a selfie um he had a big long line
of uh athletes waiting to get to catch
up with him so we left them too oh true
was he was he probably the biggest name
you bumped into
yeah the on a couple of basketballers
that played for france i can't remember
it and i didn't know him but all her
boys knew
knew him he was the guy that got the nba
shut down for kovac when he touched all
the mics if you remember
he had coty had covered the next day
so by all accounts he gets 30 30 million
u.s a year so i guess he's a pretty big
star in the nba but um
similar to you
it's real similar
i just love seeing the new zealand
athletes um i love seeing the way they
went about their work and yeah it was
pretty cool to say to watch those roars
come back with so many medals yeah for
sure
anyway mate that's bloody good run down
on the olympics that's good stuff but we
need to get through a little bit of your
story as well
um great scotsman
who you must you must just pinch
yourself sometimes realizing where you
are now coaching the new zealand seventh
side coming from scotland pretty weird
scottish bloke just who's come over to
new zealand and
i'm now coaching the pinnacle of new
zealand sport which is uh the all black
seven sides so it must be pretty surreal
eh yeah i think it's probably it's felt
more surreal over the last couple of
weeks at the olympics for sure yeah so
but yeah you're right it's you know
something that said to me
10 years ago or 12 years ago when i
first came to taranaki you know you'd be
head coach of all black sevens you'd
probably have laughed at them but i
think being at the right place at the
right time you know taranaki we were
really lucky to be involved in a
province that
had loads of good people and
gave people opportunities you know again
you were involved with the siblings the
last time i was helping out as an
assistant
you know that was after two or three
years to be in the country so certainly
it felt like i was in the right place at
the right time a lot of the time and got
really good opportunities um
taking this role on from you know from a
15 team in london i guess is a little
bit strange and
but you know i wouldn't have changed it
for the world now it's um
it's a great team to be part of and um
the last four years have been being held
all right so let's go back to your um
scottish days uh growing up i know your
old man was a scottish legend um
i think he won the grand slam your
cousin is a scottish legend as well greg
laidlaw top point scorer of all time
you're also now
a legend as well so mate rugby's massive
and your family was was it always a big
part of your family growing up yeah it
was um i don't know how many people know
the borders of scotland the south
it's uh traditionally the rugby area of
scotland uh real rural uh small town
um similar to taranaki i guess made up a
lot of little towns um
jeb was a town we we grew up in it's
only i think four four and a half
thousand people
so yeah it was um
i don't think it was any any other
option really i played golf in the
summer and rugby in the winter that was
it and um
yeah scattered around the rugby club
chasing after an old man and uh used to
go out the trainings and stuff on a
tuesday thursday night and run around
thinking you were um you know you were
playing for scotland so it was
it was always always in your blood and
as i say it was never fail you were
forced and made to play rugby just
because your old man did and
certainly had a couple of periods in
your life where you kicked back a wee
bit around the
you know probably your old man playing
playing international sport took up
skateboarding for a year but i was i
wasn't very good at that so
i had to go back to play rugby so
so that's um yeah it's a real
traditional rugby area mate and um you
know bloody lucky to have the
childhood that he had um you know
playing sport and as i say being able to
run around the rugby club whenever you
chose um saturdays or tuesdays and
thursdays and
yeah it was cool and did you take rugby
seriously or when did you start taking
rugby seriously and think that it could
be come something yeah well rugby you
know even when i first played senior
rugby when i was 18 wasn't professional
i think it went professional maybe this
the year after that 95 96.
so when you grew up um you took it
serious because you wanted to play well
and
but like looking back now man we had no
idea around where the game would go and
um it could become a career and
you know i guess i was one of those
players in that transitional period
where you became
um you became a professional because you
got paid but not necessarily because
you were an actual professional um
so
you know probably enjoyed ourselves
maybe too much off the field
looking back now certainly my 15s
we had some good fun off the field but
we were rubbish on it um
and ironically i was probably more
professional when i played sevens
and didn't really get paid very much
money i ended up working part-time and
played sevens part-time so
so yeah that early part of my career was
you know a real transition both for
rugby but also for me to think all right
well rugby is now becoming
you know a genuine option around the
career and
i go into rugby development through
through playing siblings that allowed me
to
do rugby development from uh my club
side jet forest and yeah i guess you
know when you finished playing rugby i
was a bit like well what do you do now
so i was lucky enough to get a job with
with a council east lothian council
doing rugby development full time and it
sort of opened up my eyes to to actually
being organized there right with the
armed officer and
um got a sports team at a council i
think there's seven or eight different
sports i've done that for just over a
year before i moved to new zealand and i
loved i loved that experience that's
what opened up my eyes to
i guess properly doing a job rather than
just filling it in to allow you to play
rugby so so yeah i was
that big transitional period really for
rugby mate where you know eventually
started realizing it could become a
career so what stopped you from playing
rugby what what ended the career in the
end when i moved to new zealand yeah i
just looked way too hard
[Laughter]
now when i moved um i was yeah i was on
the wind down
2008 i was playing club rugby for jed
and was actually coaching at the same
time and
uh car and i moved
moved to taranaki in 2008 with with her
first uh little girl olivia
so she was only one and we moved to the
other side of the world you know i
thought continuing to play and going out
and joining that club was probably not
ideal when
you'd moved your family to the other
side of the world social rugby and
taranaki might have led to a few late
nights on a saturday wouldn't it so
so it's probably a wise idea looking
back um
the only time i played rugby in new
zealand was for two copper senior
thoughts
so khan and olivia went home for six or
eight weeks
so that's where i actually joined two
cup of senior thirds and played uh
played a few games and
my claim to fame is we'd be we'd be uh
be the mighty coastal in the final
smiley bar and robo were both playing
and robo was the ceo at the time so i
took my medal in on the monday morning
to a whips meeting on the monday morning
just uh
just to give rubble some [ __ ] uh in the
monday morning meetings that was quite
quite good fun so what were you halfway
yeah i was a half back and then i became
a first five and looking back that was
probably you know i was i was a decent a
decent half back as a as a youth player
yeah and when i moved to first five uh
really through my club around 12 i think
i was about 20
um i was an okay first five but i was a
better half back i should
i should have continued to play halfback
um
as you know jimmy i've got a
i was a good communicator
because i've got a big mouth
and
i was reasonably aggressive so the good
defender yeah um
but as a first five i was a [ __ ] goal
kicker terrible light kicker so i had to
develop those areas of the game and um
yeah probably never good enough to then
you know continue in the professional
game
no regrets though no regrets on your
rugby career nah
yeah you could go back and have a wee
wonder yourself at 1920 you probably say
don't enjoy yourself of the pitch as
much but
man i've got some good
stories go on give us give us one of
them
well i was just um yeah he didn't know
any different did you just
you know i remember the borders team we
were fully professional and we arranged
to stay on in dublin after we played
lansdowne on friday night because it was
scotland ireland on the saturday and man
what a couple of days we had and then
then you go back to work on monday and
you're meant to be a professional rugby
player again
i haven't had two days two days on the
guinness
tough times you and davey gray would
have got up to all sorts when you were
um traveling together too i don't know
yeah he's worse than me he's uh he's a
hell of a lad it's actually been um it's
been quite cool if you know but davey
davey's been involved with us with the
siblings the last couple of months um we
finished training blair mills took off
to japan
so we've got davey involved because he's
only doing three days a week with
hurricanes so it was um
that was that was pretty surreal two
sort of local boys we've known each
other since we were
15 16 we played rugby against each other
and i'm with each other and so for the
two of us to be involved over the last
couple of months has been pretty cool um
yeah getting him involved with the team
another thing i want to talk to you
about is your time at the hurricanes you
obviously went down there and became an
assistant coach so any anything that
stands out around your time down there
i genuinely love my time with the
hurricanes um
they were the team i used to get up at
you know six o'clock in the morning to
watch on sky sports whenever super rugby
was on back home and um
i remember uh mark hammett phoning me up
and asking me if i was keen to
to go down in a skills role initially
him and a llama uh asked me if i would
go down and help out and
i think that probably felt more surreal
than than any of the jobs i got i was
man i was so nervous going hurricanes
and uh
thinking about coaching all blacks and
you know some of the best players in the
world um
and yourself and yourself
intimidating um
so yeah you know the main thing would be
man it was a great place to work and the
players appetite the hurricanes when i
was there was was always to be better um
and work their ass off to to be really
good you know i guess that that year we
lost the final 2015 would would be the
easiest memory around um good and bad
you know who played some amazing rugby
that year and then came up short in that
that final against the highlanders who
you know who did a job on us i thought
that day but it's similar to all the
memories really isn't it with rugby it's
it's the people you meet and
um the experience you have you know i
wouldn't have changed the thing at the
hurricanes it was um
you know getting to work with different
coaches getting to work with ham on a
llama but then boydy coming in and
um plums you know two two really
experienced coaches that
run the team in different ways um
allowed me to see
to see that as well as is working with
hammer nalama the initial years and
the iwati and chrono
over over both
both sets of coaches so
it was good times wasn't it you know we
had um some amazing leaders or players
that wanted to grow the game um
body yourself tim bateman you know it's
three players that really
really ran the team it was um it was
quite an easy team to work for in some
regards um the skill level and ability
um didn't put too many handbrakes on how
you wanted to play the game
how old were you when you went into the
environment um 2013 what's that
so yeah 33 34. oh true so yeah
reasonably young i guess um
certainly working with guys like conrad
and frank saying that you know who he
felt were almost the same age as you at
the time yeah
um
you know felt a little bit intimidating
if i'm being honest at the start yeah um
but i remember guys like sneaky
um you know how to look at his game one
day around some of his tackle stuff and
i showed him a couple of things and he
was he was a bit like can you have a
look at this every week
and i was like yeah i can have a look at
it and um he's like oh it's good for
somebody just have a look at you know
the technical part i think once the
players get a little bit older and
become captains and leaders a lot of the
tension in their game becomes around um
you know either the tactical or the
leadership side of the the team
yeah so i think we're initially went in
just doing skills and just looking at
you know how
how people caught the ball or what the
path was like or
how that looked you know in the attack
shape or defensive structure um
i think players really appreciated that
so i've got
you know got really good relationships
with some of the senior players which
allowed me to
to probably relax a little bit and and
realize you know i didn't need to prove
myself and
i think once i've done that it allowed
me to coach you know just coach how uh
how a scene fit and
um as i say i really enjoyed those
relationships with some of those senior
players certainly in the initial stages
and you talked about the 2015 final i
know hindsight's an easy thing for
coaching but would you have done
anything differently
um going into that final it's that
finals come up a lot throughout this
podcast through the relationships that
i've i've made but there's been lots of
different takes on it what what's your
take
oh
yeah well we'd have done something
different i'd like to think so um
certainly want a different result um
i think the the biggest thing i've
i've took from sevens that i think we
need to take into 15s is adoption
so and and sevens we we play six
different teams um
over a weekend um you know the first
three you're going to get
and you don't really know say the
olympics you had no idea who you're
going to get because it was the if you
won your group it was going to be 8th
so you actually had no idea who you're
going to play
so how we've prepared the team is really
trying just to adapt to different
scenarios rather than worrying about a
certain opposition
you know and if you look if you look at
that game again um
the highlander's ability to push up high
and outside and turn us back in and stop
us getting to width and put it under a
lot of pressure in that game
now did we ever train adapt to that
picture
um you'll be able to remember better
than me but
i think no would be the short answer
yeah we didn't expect it
nah
so i think you know where my coaching
and how i would want to prepare a team
now is to expect everything and be ready
for different solutions
um you know the they come around the the
mall where where they came around and
sacked their mall
and we never really touched the ball
again that last 10 so 15 minutes
was another good example of something we
hadn't expected
so i think you know that one game mate
back then was i experienced enough to
talk at this not um you know i think
jamie joseph and tony brown
are obviously bloody good coaches and
you know fair play to them they prepared
their team really well um
you know and even even that olympic
final you start thinking man we didn't
adjust to one of their kickoffs to start
the kickoff
and we adjusted the second time but not
the first time in the scored office of
the second one so there's like another
example where we still haven't quite you
know got this team
adapting quick enough um because i think
that's where the games went you know
being prepared for
the unexpected but also being able to do
the same to a position yeah
so you know would have changed it you
know i think i think maybe now we could
change it if you could go back by the
time
you know we only lost two games the
whole season didn't we um
we couldn't really have asked for much
more and that's rugby mate that's
you know some teams on the day are
better than others and you know both
both the hurricanes and the sevens we've
been
you know bloody good at times and that
year was the same and until we lose two
games yeah and then you moved over to
london iris so what brought that move
about for you
well i think i think initially we were
thinking about moving home um
car and i we know with two daughters um
and then our third was actually on the
way as we made that decision so you know
we've been away for a long time
initially came to new zealand for a year
that's how i sold it to karen that we
would um we'd come for a year and
we'd go home so so really we were you
know sort of 18 months up to maybe
making that decision and then
actually coached samoa
national team with tom coventry and
alameramia
in the northern tour in the in the
november previous um
and tom and i you know were spoken to by
london irish so i really enjoyed working
with tom you know i liked his approach
to the game and thought you know if i
was going to go home
um or to the uk and
and work with different people i thought
going with somebody i already knew
and someday i thought you know
we would run a good team um and want to
play the game
i guess in a sort of new zealand style
it was a good opportunity so that was it
kind of just all fell into place over a
short period of time just before the
christmas
um as i say we were pregnant with emmy
tom
then had the opportunity to be the head
coach at london iris so
you know it was a decision we thought at
the time we would see us you know
eventually end up back in scotland i
guess so then what was london irish like
but getting over there trying to coach
trying to change turn this team around
turn them into a new zealand style
playing group i guess
yeah it went badly didn't it
oh you talking about hindsight jimmy
it's um
you know that's that's probably the
period of my coaching i'm most
disappointed about you know looking back
in hindsight there was things we've done
poorly you know expecting players to be
able to change as quick or adapt to how
we want to play the game
you know in hindsight was definitely a
mistake um
not really understanding maybe the the
mindset more than the skill set of the
players um because i genuinely don't
think it's a skill set issue i think a
lot of the time it's a mindset
around
how you can play the game and certainly
how you can attack um and find space
so there was heaps of stuff that first
year um you know ultimately we got
relegated from the premiership
um that was a hugely tough experience
watching um
you know a club go through that you know
i took no satisfaction whatsoever around
being involved um
you know i've seen people lose their
jobs that work for the club for
for years um you know i've seen private
owners that put in
you know five million pounds of their
own money
watch our team not not perform and
prepare as well as what everybody wanted
so it was you know it was a it was a
tough year uh we had a new baby uh we're
living in london
some days it was taking you two hours to
get home from training um
and then you arrived and turned all
around so it was uh
it was um but yeah that first year mate
was was bloody tough and and definitely
some real good lessons around
around change around dealing with people
around building relationships um
that's put me in a way better place in
my coaching and then the second year you
know i genuinely really enjoyed the
second year
um being in the championship yeah the
rugby was potentially not quite as good
as
as a premiership or super rugby but
actual coaching in the way the players
applied themselves as second year
um you know having you on board not not
being someone you're a podcast but
having you know somebody that
a coach can rely on um to help run the
game and build the game
you know is a huge thing and
certainly it was appreciative um from
mine having you involved and
um the coaches we worked with you know
the young english coaches with um
dodge and deck and kendo i thought
brought a real enthusiasm and a real
love for their club
um
they rubbed off on the team um and
winning helps you know we we understand
that like we won
i think we won almost every game then we
lost the jersey away
you know i think there's one other game
we lost that whole year but
um i genuinely enjoyed giving back to
the club and getting them promoted um i
felt
you know i felt after the first year
it's probably the right thing for me to
do was to
was to stay on a couple of really good
opportunities um looking back um
you know one was a big irish team that
you know maybe i should have took the
job it was a pretty cool job but you
know i felt it was the right thing to
to stay in and give back
and try and get the team you know at
least promoted back in the premiership
and help with recruitment for for the
following year and how did you find
working with brendan venter
awesome
it was um
man i loved working with him he was
i've never seen anybody challenge people
as much um
he was um
i don't know if anybody listening i'll
know brandon that well but he's
obviously a doctor so some of my best uh
chuckles behind the scenes was him and
brian o'leary they had a miracle going
you know going at it around whether a
player was going to be available for
selection or
what sort of treatment he was going to
get but brian could give as good as he
got and
there were some great days and then
obviously being a south african me
wanted to play with ball in hand and
find space and him wanting to kick it
and mull it was uh we had some really
good discussions but well i was found
with brandon was me if he
if you could argue your point
and you had um
you know a fair reason around why you
thought something would work he
he would he would argue but he would he
would then either disagree and commit or
i would have to disagree and commit but
he was um
i like a lot around you know well you
see i mean how positive and optimistic
and um you know he always he only looked
for effort he only wanted his players to
work as hard as he could
and he always you know he put the
pressure on the coaches to
to create the game plan and and work
with the players to be better so you
know he's
but man with some some classics behind
the scenes that's for sure he could
definitely sell the dream hey he could
have potentially one of the uh worst set
piece plays in history but he could sell
it like it was going to be the greatest
move ever i remember the old catapult
couple round the corner plays and he
just sold it like it was the best play
ever made up and um the boys all bought
into it and they loved it and i think we
scored off it
we didn't i think we scored uh
yeah that's right
but that's i guess that's that a
coaching sometimes isn't it the
yeah being able to sell the dream and
motivate your players and you're right
you know it's
i guess no idea is a bad idea if
everybody buys in and rips in so
so you're right he was um he was a good
salesman but
yeah i used to wait and i'm coming in on
those monday mornings he'd fly from
south africa overnight and i'd come in
on a monday and just go nuts till the
game on a saturday i'd leave again
and all the coaches will be at that
right we can relax again for the next
three or four weeks till he comes back
i think the players were like that in
the meetings too especially claire cowan
yeah he was uh he wasn't shy and putting
on the spot was he oh [ __ ] no oh it was
good times no but definitely some good
some good memories there uh london irish
no doubt and then you obviously got the
opportunity to coach the new zealand
seven so how did that one come about
because i think you were supposed to
stay for another year weren't you
yeah it was um
yeah i guess the the team didn't go so
well in
the last olympics um you know there was
always talk tits would probably finish
up after that
um having been involved with the team
previous you know i used to keep in
touch with don tricker and tony phelp
who
at the time were in charge of the
recruitment of the next head coach so
they just got in touch you know that's
what my thoughts were around potentially
putting my name
my name forward to coach the team and
yeah i guess long story short you know
if i stuck my name and i discussed that
with karen this time and then surprised
her with a job opportunity in new
zealand like the
the ten years previous or the eight
years previous but um
yeah i guess like
living back in the uk we thought we'd
get home a lot see family a lot more
but as you know when you're coaching in
england and you've got
40 something games a year
i probably see my family less than i did
when i was in new zealand you know
because nobody would come down for six
weeks at a time or we wouldn't go back
there for six weeks at a time and i
think we've obviously been influenced as
a family around you know lifestyle and
how we live um by new zealand so the
opportunity to come and coach a team
be involved um quite an exciting time i
thought for the team where you know
we're going to centralize
there was com games world cups olympics
um you know on the field
um i thought it was quite an exciting
opportunity so
yeah if you'd said to me again two years
previous that would end up moving back
to new zealand i would have said you
were mad but i kind of just fell in a
place against a right place at the right
time and
you know london irish
allowed me to finish up a year early and
yeah we jumped on that flight again in
the july after the season and you
obviously had an instant impact with the
new zealand sevens team you had some
great success straight away winning all
sorts of competitions and coach of the
year awards
yeah it was um
i've never been more nervous ever and
that's included in the last few weeks
when we played our first game against
samoa who tit was now coaching
in dubai and we're second game on it was
9 20.
and um
we are you know i had no idea if what
we've done in pre-season you know around
the culture around um
our game was so simple but we built a
lot of stuff off the field around you
know team culture and there was a couple
of things from that that first game one
we decided to sing
before the game
so before we go to warm-up we now sing
and it's become
yeah second nature to us now by the time
we were in a changing room with wales
and as you know in dubai the changing
rooms are not overly big
and i looked at tim mickelson and scott
curry and i was like
are we singing
and we were a bit like you know as you
can probably tell us
us battlers are probably not the best
singers in the team
and um i always remember timmy saying he
would do anything to try and win
says all right let's sing so we actually
went into the corridor and sang
and i can remember the feeling change
around
feeling connected and nice and relaxed
all of a sudden but
i went to that that game that tunnel
and um i don't know what it looked like
but i felt like i was gonna be sick in
one mouth i was that nervous
and then we tactically decided we'd kick
long leave the rocks we thought samoa
would eventually
you know turn the ball over or we'd get
an opportunity
they kept the ball for two minutes and
scored at the other end
um
so i went on at half time and told the
boys to get in the rocks and they said i
thought you should stay in the rocks and
forget what i said just get in there and
get the ball
and i think it was sioni i think sioni
scored a try he broke through
under the posts and uh and scored a try
and won the game um
and then we got to the final couldn't
believe we got we got to the final in
lost in south africa and then the
following week in cape town we actually
beat south africa in the semi-final in
front of 50 000 and
uh we beat argentina in the final um
and we thought we'd cracked it and we
never won another world series
tournament that year um
but you know we we put all our eggs
really and trying to win early um and
then they come games and world cup was
that year so we
you know we really made the plan to try
you know genuinely peak at those
tournaments you know it's um
it's a bit different than sevens we you
know we are a peak in sport we were
three pinnacles over four years
it's you know when you wear a black
jersey everybody expects you to win all
the time but
in the man series when it's so
competitive if you if you try one all
the time um deliberately to win all the
time it's
it takes a lot it takes a lot to win
every week um and then to try and peak
you know for a come games and world cup
becomes even harder so
so yeah we made our plans that year to
physically and sort of technically
tactically emotionally peak at the
common games
and um you know we made some decisions
around sending a development team to
hong kong the weekend before that you
know some people criticized but
you know you were only going to get to
australia on the sort of tuesday before
you played um
you know and as it turned out it worked
really well the boys were in amazing
condition you know game was in a really
good spot um
you know they went on to beat fiji in
the final and then the world cup
we've done the same we sort of
sacrificed um you know that middle that
last part of the year to really you know
try to recondition and rebuild some
parts of our game
to then try and play really well in san
francisco and you know that was an
amazing event at the
uh a t stadium at the the baseball
stadium you know we played fiji in a
semi-final in front of you know phallic
there was twenty thousand for jeans in
the in the crowd at the time and
you know they always had all the rock
stars there over and drandra and
uma and nakarawa and all these boys and
that's one of the games that you'll
never forget you know how well we played
that semi and then we had to dig deep
against england in the finals so
so yeah we were you know it was
i think some of it was potentially luck
i think some of it was the heart of what
happened over the last couple of years
senior players were
were hugely motivated to make change in
the team and changing their performance
which allowed us to then push them and
you know again i used timmy a lot of
time but
i remember my first meeting with timmy
came with his little ipp sheet and at
the top he just had new era how good can
i be yeah
so for a coach seeing your captain and
senior player
talk like that and anybody that knows
you know who knows timmy
his mindset to try and improve every day
is as good as i've seen an annie rugby
player you know alongside scars and some
of the senior players those two really
drive
wanting to be better they're never
satisfied where their games are
so
so yeah that was um it was a cool first
year and that's 100 the reason why
they've been in the team for so long
playing so well still competing at the
highest level so
you can just see what a difference it
makes to any any player right yeah you
know if you look at the olympics i
thought scars was the best play in the
tournament alongside andrew newstub um
i thought the way he drove the team and
he's he sort of fight to win those games
the way he led us
um i thought he was outstanding um
you know and timmy played bloody well
too and
and both of them you know are 34 33 are
physically in the best shape of their
career
you know across the board um you know
timmy maybe he doesn't quite run the
same bronco as he used to but
he's a lot stronger and he's he's faster
than he used to be um you know some of
the gps numbers and jump numbers were
we're all pb and for for the olympics so
that you know again shows you the the
work they've done over the last few
years to keep themselves in really good
condition and
they're great professionals um
you know really really good
professionals as a lot of the players in
the team are
you know the sacrifice a lot over the
last
the last few years and certainly the
last six eight months you know the boys
have really you know knuckled down and
becoming
the best physical shape they've ever
been in and you talked about um your
successful first year coaching the squad
and the accolades that came with it you
won the new zealand coach of the year
you won all sorts of coaching
awards how did you feel receiving these
sorts of awards
i think as a coach you sometimes feel a
bit embarrassed um i'm not sure what the
percentage of the difference a coach
actually makes there's a
there's a couple of football studies
that it's somewhere between five and ten
percent sure
they make that difference so i think
when you read that he probably keeps
your own ego in check that you're
actually not making that much of a
difference um
and yeah it's nice for people to you
know to see the coach of the year but
man it's um
you know i think it's a myth if you
think you're a coach that makes all the
difference so
i just you know i genuinely wanted
players to get recognition mate i i
think
i think the sevens players in new
zealand don't get the recognition they
deserve um i genuinely think
uh you know i've been lucky enough to
work with
with world-class players um
both here
you know i work with a lot of
internationalists in england all blacks
and sevens players and
you know i can genuinely say these boys
work as hard and as diligently um and as
passionately around the
the rugby is any player i've worked with
so
i'd love to see guys like scars and tim
mickelson and
you know guys like joe webber we've got
some of this younger crew coming and
andrew neistat tony and chu nashu um you
know guys like dylan collier the
man they're good rugby players and i
think you know if
if anybody getting recognition it should
be these boys around how dedicated they
are to to this sport and
how hard to train you know
i genuinely think 15 players some 15
players would love to play sevens
but you know potentially some of their
own ego and their own their own little
worlds will stop them putting themselves
in this window because
because it's bloody difficult you get
exposed if if you're not up to doesn't
matter how many times you've played for
a super rugby team with all blacks
if you've got a deficiency in your game
simmons will find it real quick whether
it's mental physical technical
i'll find it pretty quickly um
so yeah you know i've got you know
genuinely no real interest um
in my own awards i just want the players
and the team to get the recognition of
the work they do and
you know hopefully they can get that so
what's next for what's next for big
clark glade law you've finished your
olympic campaign what's what's the plans
going forward what bike
the marathon
no no real plans um you know we
okay with two weeks down here and
um it's actually quite nice to
to not have too much to think about
we're going to do some of our reviews
over the next 10 days and try and tidy
some of that up so when we come out
we'll get some leave the players and
staff we'll take some time um you know
just to decompress and get away from the
game and
um i think some of the challenges we've
got obviously going forward is is
getting out the country um
or getting back into the country you
know so there is seven tournaments
happening um october november december
around the world
uh world rugby is keen to try and make
these world series tournaments happen
but you know with quarantine still
existing in new zealand um
you know even for people like us that
have been tested you know we've been
tested every day for two weeks
we're fully vaccinated
but we still have to do the two weeks in
miq so
unless the government change you know
what the protocols might look like
around coming back in the country we're
going to struggle to
to go out you know whether it's a
financial
um issue you know because it costs a
fair bit money to put a team through miq
or
even just space in miq you know most of
the beds are taken up i think between
now and
now in october november um
if it still exists the cape town
tournament it would mean we were in
quarantine for
for christmas you know so i don't think
any of us are that fired up to
to have christmas in miq so
it's pretty uncertain i think in in you
know in new zealand's seven's world um
let's say hopefully your borders can you
know slightly relax around
um certain criteria if you've been
tested a lot or you know you're fully
vaccinated plus testing could it be a
shorter period you know things like that
so
if that changes you know then then maybe
we can get you know back overseas and
get back in that world series if it
doesn't
then i don't know we've got um we've got
like a guest spot on your podcast that
can come on and
yeah definitely
good coin too
do like a monthly like a monthly catch
up yeah it sounds um
so so yeah short term have a break jimmy
and um you know relax relax spend some
time we've been away for two months
um you know it's another part that i'm
i'm very proud of the team i've never
had a player or a member of management
moan around being away
you know it's going to be eight weeks
we've been away from our families and um
you know we were in townsville and
the way everybody just applied
themselves and and knew that's what it
was going to take was you know was
awesome um
but i think everybody's going to be
pleased to get home to their families
and friends um in a couple of weeks time
is that sevens for you now is are you
set on sevens or would you be open to a
transition back to the 15s game
yeah i'm definitely hoping to transition
back into 15s if um you know i can get
the right opportunity and
um i do miss 15s i miss and then oh i
miss it in some ways i'd love i'd love
15's teams to apply themselves how the
sims boys apply their selves with with
very little um
you know the way this team applies
themselves to training and
and cracks on and doesn't look for
excuses
doesn't really want to influence how
long they train or
what they're doing training and just
embrace what's in front of them
you know i'd love the challenge just
seeing if you get a 15's team to really
embrace it like that um
because there's
a lot of different dynamics when you've
got um tight fives and forwards coaches
and line-outs and malls and so i'd love
the challenge to see if you could apply
you know how a sevens week looks and
how a seventh team operate if you could
put that into fifteens i missed the game
of 15 you know the complexity of
you know trying to get 40 boys and a
squad to understand how you want to play
the game and
you know and i genuinely miss the
week-to-week um playing games you know
it's
whether it's tournaments every you know
six weeks or it's 15 games every week i
miss you know i've missed that over the
last year
um if it's another year where
you know we just get ready for a com
games in world cup later in the year
you know i think that'll
that'll be tough um because
we're rugby players rugby coaches you
want to play games you want the
challenge of preparing and and trying to
win
so so i missed that in 15 so i think you
know over time if
you know that opportunity can come up
and the right place at the right time
then you know then cool if not you know
another year in my contract with sevens
and
um you know i'll try and prepare the
team as best we can through towards
you know the the come games in world cup
and then you know you're only two years
out from the next olympics so i guess
you know who knows if i've got another
full three years and i'm jeremy because
it you know it'll take
he's got to make sure i'm the right
person i guess going forward to take the
team forward and
you know we've done a lot of work um to
get it set up really well so
you know if it's time for somebody to to
maybe try and take us forward over the
next year then you know we need to look
at that too sounds like you might be
back to london irish to try and get them
to adapt the sevens mindset
i've been challenged wouldn't it
get them to stop complaining geez every
time
it's actually ironic coming from a
scotsman isn't it because it was uh
blood to be to be negative and uh more
about stuff so
oh good stuff
anyway as always we've gone to our
instagram for some questions and
mate lots of well thought out questions
came in for you i guess it's um part of
your
following first one you sort of
mentioned it before
around um 15's players coming to sevens
but what stopped caleb clark from
traveling to the olympics
game time really man
the year before you know that you talked
about cover did it have an impact
you know it definitely had an impact on
on caleb um you know he probably just
hadn't quite
found his rhythm again
that real urgency in the sevens game
takes a wee bit of time to get back when
you lose it and
you know we talked a lot we had to pick
the team on the monday after the
townsville tournament which was a month
before we played
now would it have been the same team we
picked if we could have waited three
weeks i'm not sure it would have been
um i think it might be in a different
team mate and caleb had certainly been a
part of those discussions um
but just the mix you know we had even
little things like anthony had uh had an
injury so if we if if anthony didn't
come right or did come right if he was
in the team and he didn't come right we
could make a change or caleb would have
come in if
if he had been out the team and come
right we couldn't have put him in so
there's
there's some different selection
criteria you've got to go through to to
name that team as early oh yeah so i
think you know that plus caleb you know
not been able to be with us the same as
he had been the year before
you know he'd come in in the the
november um by the time we played in
vancouver
you know which was like nearly six
months he was going really well when he
transitioned back into 15 so
you know i feel disappointed for caleb
that
you know that was the case um but you
know ultimately we we felt we picked the
team that you know gave us the best
chance of winning
interesting
okay next question this one is from uh
your great mate cristiano eaves he's
knows best who is slash was the best and
worst player to coach
conrad smith
what best and worse
yeah he's best and worth because on his
good day he was amazing but man when he
when he's competitive street came out i
seen him walking off it i gave him a
walking touch one day and a half
um that was a classic wasn't it so
oh
man it's i've been so lucky to quote the
amount of players that i could say had
been the best um
would be huge um you know the current
players that i work with at the minute
are
some of the best attitudes i've seen to
to training and wanting to be good so
you know i put those boys at the top and
probably coaching a
jed
jed forest back in the day that was a
handful of a few my worst players in
there when i was a player coach
trying to coach you
trying to cut your best mates who
knew all your ins and outs and then you
know trying to be serious as a coach was
quite interesting
[Laughter]
oh good stuff this one's from stub
nugget how many times has he been called
craig and what's wrong with the song
slice of heaven
yeah we'll start with slice of heaven
nothing's wrong with it apart from stubs
he sings it um
i'll tell you a quick story on that so
we sit as a city we sing before games so
we sing
samoan fijian yeah tongan and and maori
songs yeah the year of the commonwealth
games we went to vegas we decided we
should sing
sing in english
so
we we did an ensemble of slice of heaven
with stubsy leading
leading it and we sang
we sang it before we played we played uh
uruguay and nearly lost
and played terrible and then we sang it
again and played argentina and actually
lost
so we we threw out and um we never ever
sang it again apart from when we have a
few beers so
so that's where that that comes from um
stubsy when we're a little bit down
after the final last week there was a
few tears and a few of the boys were
singing some of her songs and it was um
yeah it was getting pretty dark for
for 15 minutes stubsy
stubs he brought us around by a full
rendition
of a slice of heaven so you got the boys
back up a bit for
a time and then the craig's story is for
some reason everywhere i go
all the time um interviews you can read
it even online after olympics people
call me craig lidler
i had a guy text me and call me the
other day
and he was obviously going out his way
to call me by my name on a text but he
called me craig four times
um
i got introduced on the stage a big
function one time it's craig ludlow
um
so it's kind of a running joke in the
team now that i just get called craig
and
um to be fair i've been called way worse
than craig
oh no yeah
oh craigie okay good stuff okay next one
uh when coaching at a high level how
important is the balance of work and fun
in the sessions yeah well i can't
understand anybody that wants to come to
work and not have fun
now what fun looks like in a training
session
um
you know can vary obviously but
having an enjoyable environment where
you come to work and want to enjoy
yourself and you know have fun on and
off the field
is a no-brainer so i think in any
session the ability to switch between
you know focused work and and
an edge and growth is is kind of how we
use it so you know having you know we're
trying to win olympic games it's a
pretty serious um
serious thing we're trying to do but
we take yourself too seriously the whole
time you know then ego and
unenjoyment will
quickly creep into your environment so
we genuinely try and have a lot of fun
in connection as a group um you know me
i enjoy
i enjoy barnard and having fun um
i'm glad you're not in the team doing uh
doing your info now i'm the head coach
um for some of you
some of your infos the hurricanes around
head coaching in your songs and
if i remember correctly your victor veto
injury and your honeymoon was
one of my fondest memories
oh i still don't know how that happened
he got he got to go on a
mid-season holiday and i wasn't allowed
to go on a honeymoon before the
pre-season unbelievable scenes and you
you must have been a part of that
discussion with the management crew at
the time
nothing to do with it jimmy i was like
yeah i'm going honeymoon he's uh he's
not going to get a game anyway he might
as well go
and victor was actually injured if you
remember rightly and he was injured it
was
oh boy he did apologize to me for that
he did regret it but um yeah it was one
of those ones
it was good for info but uh not great
for the marriage yeah oh you're still
you're still together three kids later
so you're all right yeah yeah maybe it
was that's the reason that made us
stronger yeah that's it thanks to boitie
resilience yeah that's it next question
this one's from mr alex lillington
sarasota star
can you please explain your hampton
kingston analogy one more time
g'day louis if he's listening um
[ __ ] we had some good battles with louie
uh getting players to see the the
positive side of things manny could uh
drop his bottom left goodness
but
oh i love the seppuccino that man he was
competitive but he didn't know how to
show it when he was there when things
weren't going good but um
yeah we use the the
kingston bridge
to try and get a phase attack so one
side would be harmed the other side
would be kingston and use the kingston
bridge
to try and shape which players stayed on
which side of the fields
if i remember correctly in a 1331
15 shapes so
yeah i thought the boys really enjoyed
that
it certainly helped i'll tell you that
much um
so
louie obviously loved it louie can
relate to it well that's it's uh you
talk about being sticky doesn't it so
he's obviously remembered it so it's uh
done its job
andrew was saying okay next one if you
could choose one player in world rugby
to play sevens who would it be
oh great question
oh man there's so many um
loving some of the french backs
um
i think everybody would love to see
damian mckenzie play sevens in new
zealand you know he's speeding agility
you know i think i think everybody would
love to see him
so yeah probably probably damon mckenzie
but manners
you know chelsea colby from south africa
he's obviously played simmons before um
you know he played at the start his
career
he'd be a hell of a handful now that um
you know now he's matured and the type
of player he is
but yeah i'd love to see some of the
you know some of those french backs
obviously some of the fijian boys that
play for france i've obviously played
and
fuckitava and these boys have played
before so
um i'd love to see a really good forward
you know i'd love to see
i'd love to see are they have a crack at
it again or
you know players like that that kind of
transition the real physicality from
from 15s and put it back in the seventh
so
yeah that'd be
it'd be a long list you may be some
pretty cool uh players you could pick in
there isn't it but if i have to pick one
damien mckenzie so if he's listening you
can maybe see if uh still impacts he
wants to have a craft
it's only three years okay yeah who is
the best sevens player in the world in
your opinion
oh the fijian boys are you know jerry
two eye and two mamba um
daryl lange the forward that plays
is an amazing rugby player um
he's probably got his big influences
anywhere in the game um
so yeah probably daryl lange's
he's the biggest handful when you've got
to play against them i think i genuinely
think some of our boys would be up there
i think when you look at how scars
played um
in the olympics you know if you're
picking a world seven
he would have been in it um alongside
stubs he probably is is the halfback so
yeah again there's so many boys at the
minute that you know like a long bottom
plane for australia man he's a handful
to play against when he's fit and
healthy and
um you know he's a real point of
difference for their team so each team's
probably got two or three you're like
wow you'd you know you'd love to work
with them if if you could pick a world
sevens team it would be
hell the crew but daryl
he's up there he's he's he's a great
rugby player i like it okay this is an
interesting one when i read it made me
really think about it but
who would win a sevens game between a
team made up of all blacks or the new
zealand sevens team three months prep
yeah that'd be a good game um three
months prep i'd back us to
to have the team to to still win if you
give them six months prep it'd be
really interesting you know that
let's be disrespectful to sevens players
you know around the world 15s is still
where players want to be and
you know i'm sure a lot of our players
have grown up wanting to be you know
full-time um 15s players and
you know that's where the money is um
you know i guess that's where people
think is the pinnacle of the
the game so ultimately the best players
you know around the world and all the
all the countries not just new zealand
are playing 15s you know and i think
that
that question would be the same for
france south africa australia you know
all the major
rugby playing countries apart from fiji
the best players are playing fifteens um
so you know if you give them six months
to to understand the game and
you know you've got to remember most new
zealand boys have played sevens of some
sort at some stage so
you know if you had jack
two year forwards then have both played
international sevens
you know if you had rico yuani and bodhi
they both were international sevens
uh richie moana would go pretty good i
would imagine um he might be top of the
list actually to play sevens yeah george
bridge
yeah
yeah well you've got george bridge doing
mckenzie will jordan would be a pretty
good side wouldn't it it'd be cool to
watch actually yeah it would be a cool
game to see like even if
it wasn't three months prep just even
less than that because
obviously the game's so different now
like that you need that fitness you need
it is a different skill set but like you
said given a six month prep
you might be able to change that but if
the game happened like in a month that
would be a cool watch i reckon uh it
would be a good game i'm not sure after
our two weeks in quarantine and a couple
of weeks off but
yeah and as i said
it would
[Music]
it'd
be
great to get some of those boys to stick
their hands up wouldn't it sure would
okay next one what happened to him in a
night out in jersey this is from another
great scottish man scott steele
i'm not sure he's talking about
[Laughter]
we certainly had um it was actually
ironic we're one of our biggest nights
with london irish didn't we and um it
was a game we lost
yeah um
so yeah it was i i the only thing i
would say is brian o'leary saved me uh
had a miracle
had a little concoction of um
recovery pills to see me right on the on
the sunday so
so yes you might have got away from us
that night um
cheers thanks for that
good times
okay two more questions
who is the best up-and-coming player
that will have a big future in the
seventh game that we do not know yet
yeah well
you know you probably know a little bit
about will warbrick has come from
nowhere really um got involved in red
bull two years ago to come to a
pre-season
um and within two years made the olympic
13. so wells
was a real prospect we were really
excited around he's a huge athlete he's
only really starting to
to believe in himself and have the
confidence to express himself you know
within the team and
um
you've seen glimpses over this year if
you've watched the games against
australia as well as the olympics that
he
he's uh you know he's a really exciting
prospect and you know a younger player
katyanavai
who's in the back end of the auckland
npc team and he's just been picked up by
them
kitty's you know he's a 19 year old
loose forward milani nana his little
brother
um again if you've seen the games
against australia or the games in
townsville he
he's got a lot of x factor he's
he's a little bit similar to rd
i see him a little bit similar to rd and
victor almost a cross between the two
you know that's doesn't say it doesn't
mean say he's going to be as good as
victor or are they but
he's got the sort of same line-out
ability as victor how quick he is at the
front of a line out or um you know that
sort of ball playing skill but
he's probably as quick as like zardi um
so he's somebody those two young boys
two young forwards that have both come
through red bull
um that maybe nobody you know didn't
play
schoolboy rugby they weren't stars
um as i say kitty's already you know
even with just you know two or three
games thus auckland are
are now seen in part of their future
which you know wasn't the case six
months ago so
so yeah we've got some good young boys
there mate we're um
you know we probably see the next
olympic team you know almost already
here which is
i think what it's going to take you know
to be able to win in three years time is
boys with a lot of experience in big
games
um
you know maybe with some of those 15
players that you're going to tap up for
us to come in and join us
well mate exciting times ahead looking
forward to following those guys
futures but last question
one piece of advice you would give to a
young sevens player
yeah man you've had some good questions
um
have um
have true humility to to stay in the
moment
i don't know if you've seen the
basketballer that played that one
[Music]
won the nba i forgot his name rubbish
with uh basketballers names i don't
follow enough but i don't know if you
heard him speak mate around what
humility looks like around stay in the
moment
and if you're too focused on what's
happened in the past it becomes ego
and you can look to the future which can
be pride but
i think having true humility that allows
you to to prepare every day to not get
ahead of yourself to not think you've
cracked it
and to work your ass off every day um
would be the best piece of advice i
could give a young player
i think people get too far ahead of
themselves too quickly
and i think we look too far ahead to
what might come or what might not come
or too far back
on things we've done in the past you
know a lot of young players get caught
up in you know first 15 rugby in
new zealand schools and under 20s and so
on but none of that actually matters
when you become a man um none of it you
know none of it really
makes that much of a difference so
i think if you can have true humility
mate to
to work hard and just whatever right in
front of you you know to whether that's
on the field or off the field jimmy it's
you know whether it's being a good
brother or son um
at that time or whether it's been a
really good young professional
i think that's um if anybody can watch
that article that young basketballer
talk
i thought he put it way better than i
ever could so so that would be my advice
um i'd probably give it to myself when i
was 19 20 um
transitioning in a semi-professional
rugby mate that is powerful powerful
advice i i even got a little bit of
goosebumps during that that could be the
best piece of advice we've had on yet
and coming from the great man clark
glade law but mate really appreciate you
coming on the podcast
you've been a massive influence on my
career made i've traveled pretty much
around the world with you with karanaki
hurricanes and london irish but mate
you've been a huge influence on my
career really appreciate what you've
done for me throughout my career and
mate it's just awesome seeing you on the
stage now that you are olympic silver
medalist and um changing the culture of
the new zealand sevens team and
the stuff that you're doing as a coach
is um unreal stuff so mate look forward
to following the rest of your journey
wherever that may be whether it is
sevens or fifteens and um mate
appreciate you coming on the podcast too
easy thanks man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]